i'll get to the kamala of it all in a
second because
this is both i think something
worthwhile for senate republicans but i
think it's also
an attitude shift that republicans
generally need to understand
but first i i actually want to take
seriously the democrats contention
that donald trump should be impeached in
his last
10 days or so in office president trump
they want to impeach
because he led an insurrection on the
government at capitol hill
and he urged his mob to go become
violent
and invade the capital and scare off all
the legislators
and this is unacceptable it's a threat
to the republic
and therefore we've got to impeach him
that's the charge now what are the facts
president trump
called his supporters to dc for a big
rally he went out and addressed that
rally
he told people to be strong and he even
told them
or i guess described how they were
inevitably going to
march to capitol hill and therefore it's
an open and shut case right well let's
let's listen to what president trump
actually said
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
[Applause]
we have come to demand that congress do
the right thing
and only count the electors who have
been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
today we will see whether republicans
stand
strong for integrity of our elections
but whether or not they stand strong for
our country
okay now you've probably heard the first
part of that
clip before you might not have heard the
second part where president trump
explicitly says
you're going to go there and peacefully
and patriotically make your voices heard
so it doesn't sound to me like he's
inciting an insurrection sounds like
quite the opposite right he's explicitly
saying
do not be violent be
peaceful now you might say look he sent
a mob of extremely angry people over to
the capitol
and said be tough you got to be tough
you can't be weak so therefore
i don't know we got to censure the
president i actually i understand the
argument
of house republicans who want to censure
the president probably wouldn't vote for
it but i
i at least understand that argument i
don't see the argument for impeachment
he didn't do the thing that they are
saying that he did and you can play the
tape and listen to it
not that evidence is going to matter all
that much in an impeachment trial
which certainly an impeachment trial of
a president who is days away from
leaving office
is purely political there's no legal
basis for it at all
so this is basically where republicans
and conservatives
are fighting the issue right now should
we impeach trump
should we censure trump should we do
nothing at all what are they going to do
to us right it's all very defensive
i'd like to propose an alternative i
think that the
the democratic-controlled house is going
to try to impeach trump
i think that the republican-controlled
senate should censure or better yet
expel
kamala harris last i checked kamala
harris is still a senator right
and will remain so until she becomes
vice president
so and i guess even if she weren't the
senate could still pass a resolution to
censure her
so why won't they do that kamala harris
did did not merely encourage
the peaceful protesters at the black
lives matter
riots all over the summer kamala harris
posted a fundraising link
for the rioters in minnesota who were
arrested
to bail them out of jail that's not
saying go over there and peacefully
protest
that's saying we are going to subsidize
your violent actions
we played a little bit of this briefly
yesterday on the show kamala harris went
on the colbert show and said
these rioters they ain't going to give
it up
i know that there are protests still
happening in major cities across the
united states i'm just not seeing the
reporting on it that i that i had that's
right
for the first few weeks um but they're
not they're not going to stop and that's
they're not this is a movement i'm
telling you they're not gonna stop
and and everyone beware because they're
not gonna stop
it is gonna they're not gonna stop
before election day in november and
they're not gonna stop
after election day and that should be
everyone should take note of that on
both levels that this isn't
they're not going to let up and they
should not and we should not
they're not going to let up and and they
should not and we should not now you
might say michael kamala is not talking
about the rioters kamala's talking about
the mostly peaceful protesters
i'm not so sure of that because there
was a lot more
violence a lot more widespread violence
during the blm riots than anything that
happened at the capitol bad as it was
but but moreover if you're going to say
that about kamala harris certainly have
to say that about trump if you're going
to say blm was mostly peaceful
surely you have to say the capitol hill
was mostly peaceful
donald trump went out there and said you
have to do this peacefully
kamala harris didn't say anything like
that not in that clip and certainly not
in the fundraising link
the fundraising link subsidizes the
violence
anything they're going to accuse trump
of anything they're going to bring up in
this impeachment trial
kamala harris is far more guilty of
the house control or the democrats
control the house rather republicans
control the senate how come it's only
ever
house democrats who are aggressing how
come it's only ever the left
who are doing anything why is the right
always on defense why won't mitch
mcconnell go out there
and at the very least censure kamala
harris
and better yet expel her if they're
going to try to impeach trump expel
kamala harris
i don't think that what what trump did
giving a rally say
say go be peaceful i don't think that's
an impeachable offense
a little questionable to send a mob down
to capitol hill but certain nothing
nothing that he did is impeachable
so so if you're going to impeach the guy
for that surely
surely we have to apply even something
close to the same standard
to the democrats who did far worse but
that's not going to happen
mitch mcconnell's almost certainly not
going to do it i mean call your
congressman
call your senator rather try to make it
happen but but
it almost certainly will not because of
this systemic problem on the right
which is that we play defense and we
roll over
and the left aggresses and aggresses and
aggresses
the la all we're talking about here is
following legal procedures
even that the right is not willing to do
kamala harris says yeah it's not gonna
stop it won't stop bail out the
criminals we're gonna have a great time
no consequences whatsoever i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts